can we just spend a minute talking about
vulnerability so many people hate this
term vulnerability especially in uh the
places of work we we're told in you know
all the sort of folks like me in the
leadership curriculum that we have to
learn to be vulnerable who wants to be
vulnerable who wants to come across as
weak um being vulnerable doesn't mean
coming across as weak you can be super
confident and vulnerable at the same
time it simply means owning your
for example if you make a mistake or you
don't understand something or something
makes sense doesn't make sense to you or
you don't feel like you have the
training for the job you've been asked
to do just own it and talk about it
that's what vulnerable means so for
example instead of being like I don't
understand that's weak versus hey uh I
completely don't understand this if
somebody can please explain it to me
you're a lot smarter than me can you
explain it to me please you're just
simply owning it or oh my God I
completely screwed up I'm an idiot
please can someone help me put this
right you're owning the mistakes you're
owning the fact that you don't
understand something and you're doing it
with confidence vulnerability doesn't
mean you're communicating weakness it
simply just means you take
responsibility and own your as
opposed to lying hiding and faking and
pretending that you know everything and
have all the answers that's what it
means to to try so I learned a little
something about feedback um if you are
in charge of something um whether you
have a position of formal Authority or
somebody has asked you to run a project
or something as things are going things
sometimes go wrong and what I've learned
is don't give feedback in the middle so
let's say you're organizing picnic and
somebody uh put the ketchup and mustard
in the wrong place um and you want to
teach them a lesson so they don't do it
again right so in the middle of the
picnic you're going to say to them hey
um put the ketchup over on the table and
make sure in the future um it that it
always goes over there right hey just
make sure next time we always put the
the lemonade next to the water in case
people want to dilute it you're giving
feedback in the middle of the thing now
you can make Corrections obviously like
if something needs to get moved but
giving feedback for next time in the
middle of the situ situation actually
doesn't work it goes in one ear and out
the other from the people um who you
want to tell rather get through the
event make little notes make a little
list of all the things you want to
improve next time and at the end sit
down with the team and say hey want to
give feedback of how we can improve
things next time next time let's always
make sure to put the ketchup on that
table let's always make sure to put the
lemonade next to the water and the point
is is people are much more open to
receiving impact on how to change things
for the future when you give the
feedback at the end of the project
rather than in the middle one of the
greatest lessons I learned about
Improvement is getting feedback and
having a good attitude about making
changes feedback as we all know is a
gift the problem is is good feedback is
the stuff we want and most of us don't
want to hear bad feedback um sometimes
if we do good work if we do work that we
think is good we give it to someone and
they don't like it we take it personally
we identify our value with our work nope
your value has nothing to do with your
work your value is how you feel about
yourself and other and others feel about
you and your work is your your work um
and we want to do good work and we want
to be valued they are not intertwined
your value is not tied to your work so
you have to learn to separate those two
I give you a real life example early in
my career I was assigned to work on a
new business F I worked in a big Ad
Agency and I was assigned to work with
somebody who I'd never worked with
before and he had a reputation of being
let's call him tough um and I had to
write a presentation for this pitch so I
went and wrote a PowerPoint presentation
and I brought it to him and he went
through with a red pen I mean like the
amount of changes he made were brutal
and I thought it was pretty good work
but it was brutal so I went back to my
desk and I did it again gave it to him
and he went through it again brutal
right and I sort of took it went back to
my desk went through it again by about
the fourth time he's still going through
it fewer red pens he's still going
through it but I was sort of weirdly
having fun I said come on it's not as
bad as you're making it out to be but I
had a sense of humor about it seven
rounds until I finally got it right and
I celebrated when I got it right but the
point is I never confused that he didn't
like my first few rounds with my value
right I believed that I was capable I
just believe I wasn't good at what I was
doing and I was learning I was learning
how to write a pitch and so it ended up
being a fantastic education I actually
formed a fantastic relationship with him
because he enjoyed the fact that I was
having fun with all of these correction
so bring a great attitude when you get
harsh advice and uh and just keep trying
again because sometimes it's fun